MORE PHYSICALITY AND SPEED.
UTILIZE TEM
LEG.
REDLINE.
EARLIER, LOGAN THOMPSON, A
GREAT SAVE.
TURNOVER BACK THTH THE WING.
THEY GO IN DEEPER.
THREADS AT AROUND THE BOARD
MINUTES HAVE GONE BY.
JONATHAN MARCHESSAULT, PLAYS
IT.
THEY WILL PLAY ON.
Ma
HE GAINS OF THE ZONE.
TRYING TO MOVE IT DOWN LOW.
TA
THEY
>> GOLDEN KNIGHTS,
YOU HAVE THE LOSING STREAK.
YOU START PLAYING BAD, THEN YOU
PLAY GREAT.
YOU CAN'T GET OUT OF IT.
IT'S IN.
HAVE NOT BEEN
THEY TRIED TO GO THROUGH.
HE MOVES IT VANCOUVER.
HE SCORES.RNS TO THE LINEUP.
THEY WILL DRIVE IT  ON THE BLOC
GOLDEN KNIGHTS, HAVE LED FOR RI
TWO GOAL LEAD.
NICE DEFLECTION BY EVGENII
DADONOV, PAST  PSON.
REBOUND, ANTHONY THE REBOUND CO
OUT.
IT HITS HIS ESCAPE.IT.
EVGENII DADONOV,  UP TO
JONATHAN MARCHESSAULT.
SCORES.
SAM REINHART, IN ESE DAYS IS RA
THIS IS FOR THEODORE.
THEY SNAP UP THE WING.RELIEF FO
CROSSING THE GOAL LINE, HE WILL